and I think London is an appalling
rent-seeking bloody economy actually
it's a rich economy but actually the
people actually producing the wealth
don't yet see very much of it compared
to the people who are you know the buy
to let landlords and the commercial
property owners who are effectively just
sucking out most of the gains but didn't
have you know a kind of modern day
feudalism take our younger stuff I'm
fine okay I'm 57 I kind of rode a bit of
a property wave I bought property when
it was still relatively sane if you look
at my junior colleagues in their 20s and
30s after they've paid tax 50 of their
increment 50 of their after-tax income
basically will go on accommodation and
transportation
now you know that's not good for the fun
economy essentially it's an enormous
absorption of what could be
discretionary wealth into the hands of
uh you know General rent seeking
landlords and um tfl